no interruptions this is important stuff
good evening i'm katie sanderson the
coordinator in charge of the young lions
program on behalf of the new york public
library and the young lions committee
it's my pleasure to welcome all of you
to the kickoff event of the fifth season
of The Young Lions program it's a very
exciting time to be a young lion we have
a tremendous program planned for you
tonight and it marks the beginning of an
outstanding year of events for those of
you who are guests coming and aren't yet
members we encourage you to join now and
take advantage of all the opportunities
that are available to young lions I want
to thank each member of the Young Lions
for your continuing support I'd also
like to give a special thanks to all the
committee members of the Young Lions for
everything you've done to make tonight's
event such a great success I'd also like
to extend a heartfelt thank you to
tonight's programs participants Jon
Stewart Rob Corddry Ed Helms David's
ever bound Ben Carlin and polish there
for taking the time to share their
insights and talents with us this
evening and last but not least
and last but not least let me extend my
gratitude to ben karlin executive
producer of The Daily Show and panelist
who helped put this all together
the amazing Gretchen Rubin Young Lions
committee co-chair Hannah Griswold
McFarland the original visionary and
founder of the Young Lions Program and
most especially though to former Young
Lions coordinator Sarah Haberman without
whom this event could not have happened
Sarah Sarah you're out there somewhere
hiding but Sarah thanks for everything
and now I'm delighted to introduce one
of the Young Lions committee co-chairs
Ethan Hawke who has the pleasure of
introducing tonight's panelists thanks
all right it's it's my absolute honor
and privilege to be here tonight to
introduce you guys anybody who saw or
heard about mr. Stewart's exploits on
crossfire it's refreshing and nice to
see honest human and alive you know
human beings on Comedy Central no hold
on but to actually see that on CNN is so
inspiring and you really just cut
through the fog and the haze that kind
of numbs me out every night and I thank
you for it and I also want to say that
I'm everybody should know that the book
that they're gonna be discussing here
America the book is on sale over there
and I'm really glad because I went to
Walmart today to pick one up and I
couldn't find one and that was weird and
so I'm happy that they have him over
here any man that is banned at Walmart
is so much to be proud of so it really
is a thrill I met I was Jon Stewart's
first guest on his first TV show back
when the only table they had was a
Knockaround hockey board and you had to
sit in the car
weird seeds or whatever I was his first
guest and so that's the honor and a
privilege for me and I had a joke that
would go with that but now I can't
remember it but I want it you get all
your names have already been induced so
I will just say that it's my pleasure to
introduce you guys you are too late
night television what Michael Jordan was
to basketball you have changed the game
and you came to play
thank you very much for the kind words
Ethan Hawke and and thank you all for
having us here we're honored to be a
part of the the fundraiser I wish that
you were all sitting further away from
me it is we're here obviously for a
fundraiser and it is clear that this
place has fallen on hard times I think I
probably speak for everybody when I say
what a [ __ ]
this is honestly this is like Versailles
what I don't understand
I'm assuming you need the money for
marble cleaner Jesus Christ we're gonna
obviously we're here tonight to talk
about and we're gonna read some excerpts
from America the book and talk a little
bit about it
we applaud you guys we know that you are
with readers and you know while we think
that's great you know don't don't forget
TV is fun so don't stop watching TV
please what I'll do is I guess we'll
start off I'll read the foreword from
the book which was written by Thomas
Jefferson who obviously he's not here
tonight although was asked he's actually
preparing for a seder
oddly enough I know I don't even know
what that doesn't make much sense does
it in October if you can't do a Jew joke
at a library in New York
where else is it gonna fly I am trying
to not say anything that will get in the
papers so here we go this is uh this is
the foreword to America the book
obviously by Thomas Jefferson please
excuse the imitation it's it's a poor
one when America the book first
approached me about penning the forward
to their tome I was surprised firstly
the foreword is not my bailiwick but
rather the declaration forgive my
conceit but if one is looking to
introduce a grand composition with a
pithy and clear pronouncement my
declaratives are second to none life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
google it if you doubt the claim also of
some concern I have been dead for has
really fit 178 years my goodness time
flies when you are no longer consigned
to your earthly vessel notwithstanding
Irv over at Warner books sent me some
galleys and I have to say funny not John
Winthrop's a comparative treatise on the
most unusual of distinctions twixt the
fair of species and her masculine
counterpart funny but funny of course
sally was less enthused you're the
author of the Declaration of
Independence a scholar a statesman this
is beneath you it's not even Network but
truth be told I was itching to get back
to the quill and paper and declaration
work is not as as steady as it used to
be
Sally may not like it but as we used to
say in the back parlors of 18th century
Paris tough titties
remember this is Jefferson hands
surprising in many respects I was also
looking forward to this opportunity to
dispel some of the mythology surrounding
myself and my fellow founders
particularly the myth of our
infallibility you moderns have a
tendency to worship at the altar of the
father's the first amendment is
sacrosanct we will die to protect the
Second Amendment so dramatic you know
why we called them amendments because
they amend they fix mistakes or correct
omissions and they themselves can be
changed if we had meant for the
Constitution to be written in stone we
would have written it in stone actually
most things were written in stone back
then you know I'm not trying to be
difficult but it's bothersome when you
blame your own inflexibility and
extremism on us not that we weren't
awesome we wrote the Constitution in the
time it takes you Nimrods to figure out
which is the eye button and which is the
nei but we weren't gods we were men we
had flaws Adams was an unbearable prick
and squealed girlishly whenever he saw a
bug Ben Franklin if crack existed in our
day that boozed up snuff machine would
weigh 80 pounds and live outside the
Port Authority and I had slaves damn I
can't believe I had slaves yes we were
very accomplished we discovered
electricity invented stoves bifocals the
lazy susan efficient printing presses
and the swivel chair but in the 18th
century it was nearly impossible not to
invent something
what if we put this refuse in a
receptacle oh my god you just invented a
sanitation system we lived in primitive
times hell I [ __ ] in a bucket and I was
the president but I digress
my point is composing the Declaration of
Independence and the Constitution was
hard work
God didn't dictate it for us to
transcribe from some sort of dictation
transcribing machine hey did I just
invent something do you have anything
like that you do okay well our purpose
was to create a living document based on
principles that transcended at times we
lived in and I think we did that we
created a blueprint for a system that
would endure which means your lazy asses
shouldn't be coasting on our
accomplishments we were imperfect it was
imperfect and we expect our descendants
to work as hard as we did on keeping
what we think is a profoundly excellent
form of government supple evolving and
relevant after reading this book you
should be better prepared to do just
that as always Thomas Jefferson PS is it
true Halle Berry is once again single if
so I'd be forever in your debt
if you would put in a good word for the
TJ oh how I loves the Mochaccino
that is the foreword to America the book
truly
truly a distasteful piece of brighter
now what we're going to do is we're
going to have the head writer of our
program is David Jeroboam who are
sitting all the way to the right there
when we thought about putting together
this book we thought about bringing sort
of the textbook format I thought was a
nice format because so much of what
people read today in terms of political
discourse are polemics and what is the
least emotional book you can write and
that would be the format of a text book
so that was the the general thought
process behind why we created the the
the the structure for we also wanted to
take the most boring Oh format as well
that's also true we want it to also be
boring so what we did is we decided to
write a narrative throughout the book so
that you could hang all those charts and
graphs and other sort of peripherals on
top of it and give it a nice full
structure David is going to read from
the first of those essays which is
democracy before American before we do
that perhaps you'd like to talk about
how in your role as the head writer of
the show you really phoned that in in
order to be able to accomplish this yeah
I remember this chapter very
indistinctly I was really kind of I had
some sense of Mia and we just kind of
just sat around and just you know I
googled a couple of facts about ancient
history and crap and I just kind of
threw some stuff together mm-hmm
that's how David works if you would now
if you would like to read I don't know
there's another podium there I don't
know if you're supposed to though okay
yeah so this is from chapter one
democracy before other way David has a
cold it's okay I'm gonna do it don't
worry I'll be fine it is often said that
America invented democracy his view is
of course an understatement
American invented not only democracy but
freedom justice liberty and time-sharing
but representative democracy is
unquestionably our proudest achievement
the creation most uniquely our own even
if the rest of the Western world would
have come up with the idea themselves by
the 1820s so why then is participation
and its most wondrous system withered
well as heirs to a legacy more than two
centuries old that is understandable why
present-day Americans would take their
own democracy for granted a president
freely chosen from a wide-open field of
two men every four years a Congress with
a 99% incumbency rate and a supreme
court comprised of a dime politically
appointed judges whose only oversight is
the icy size of death reveal a system
fully capable of maintaining itself but
our perfect democracy which neither
needs nor particularly wants voters is a
rarity it is important to remember that
there still exist many other forms of
government in the world today and that
dozens of foreign country is still
longed for a democracy such as ours to
be forcibly imposed on them so to regain
our sense of perspective and wonder we
must take a broader historical view
looking beyond America's relatively
recent success story to examine our
predecessors and their adorable failures
in this chapter we will briefly explore
the evolution of an idea
following the HMS democracy on her
dangerous voyage through the mists of
time past the straits of monarchy
surviving hurricane theocracy
then navigating around the Cape of good
food all system to arrive battered but
safe at her destined port of call
America town the human race is by nature
brutal amoral unreasonable and
self-centered but for the first few
hundred thousand years of our existence
as a species we were way too obvious
about it primitive culture centered on
survival of the individual and
occasionally survival of someone the
individual might want to reproduce with
or [ __ ]
civic institutions were not existent as
was debate which would appear later
after the invention of the frontal lobe
for prehistoric man the rule of law such
as it was could best be summed up by the
seminal case Marbury's head vs.
Madison's rock early man lived this
tenuous Darwinian nightmare for an age
or two until a peculiar thing happened
the unfinished decided they wouldn't
mind surviving either the feeble and
weak realized that we've had a good plan
they weren't going to make it out of the
Stone Age to see the wonder that was
clay alone they were mammoth meat but
together they would become a force for
the chance to see the day when their
children's children would be only 75%
covered in hair from these noble
impulses the groundwork for the first
civilization was laid Athens our Big Fat
Greek forerunners ancient Greece is
widely credited with creating the
world's first democracy if we could
travel back in time to the feta strewn
shores of 5th century BC Athens and ask
Plato to define democracy we would do it
and not just to make money gambling an
Olympics results that we being from the
future would already know Plato would
tell us and that affectionate but
non-sexual way of his that democracy is
a greek word combining the roots people
Deimos and rule Trotta
in Greek democracy political power was
concentrated not in the hands of one
person or even a small group of people
but rather evenly and fairly distributed
among all the people for purposes of
grace people means free adult males in
Greece every John Q public a Palos could
play a role in Athenian government the
main legislative body the assembly was
comprised of no less than the first six
thousand citizens to arrive at its
meetings and bear in mind no saving
seats jury duty was considered an honor
to be vied for membership in most other
civic institutions including the Supreme
Court was chosen by lot imagined
assisted in which anyone could wind up
serving on the Supreme Court
anyone think about your family friends
the guys you knew in college who would
eat dog feces for $10 now picture one of
them as your randomly chosen Chief
Justice and you'll begin to appreciate
just how [ __ ] up this system really
was now compared with American democracy
the Athenian version may seem simplistic
naive and very gay yet transcripts of
early Athenian policy debates reveal a
populace moved more by eloquence and
rationality than demagogues and
fear-mongering thankfully this type of
humane governance wasn't allowed to take
root athens grant experiment ended after
less than two centuries when in 338 BC
philip of macedon forces invaded the
city inflicting on its inhabitants the
eternal fate of the noble and
enlightened to be brutally crushed by
the armed and dumb Rome the 1st
Republicans the fall of Athens was
followed by the emergence almost
overnight of Rome at first glance its
people and for purposes of Rome people
means free adult males with property
appear to have enjoyed a system of
representative government similar to our
own true behind its facade of allegedly
representative official alert day de
facto oligarchy ruled by entrenched
political ads but the similarities don't
end there in fact the founding fathers
borrowed many of their ideas from the
roman model including its bicameral
legislature its emphasis on
republicanism and civic virtue and it's
Freudian fascination with big white
columns however there was very little
real democracy in Rome while the Senate
theoretically represented the people in
reality its wealthy members covertly
pursued pro-business legislation on
behalf of such military industrial
giants as javelin Corp United crucifix
and a cartel of resource exploiting
companies collectively known as big
aqueducts
they even monopolized the most notorious
aspect of Roman life by instituting an
orgy policy that can literally be
described as trickle-down
continue
vomitorium decide Rome's biggest
contribution to American government was
probably its legal system which codified
key concepts like equal protection
innocence until proven guilty and the
right to confront one's accusers these
very same issues would later form the
basis of both the Bill of Rights and a
mind-numbing amount of law and order
scripts but by the time of Rome's huge
millennium celebration marking the
beginning of zero AD the faint light of
Roman democracy was all but extinguished
their public had given way to Empire the
only voting to speak of took place in
the Colosseum and was generally limited
to a handful of disembowelment related
issues in time the Empire itself fell as
history teaches us all empires must
accept America it's most enduring legacy
a numerical system that allowed future
generations to more easily keep track of
Super Bowls thank you I was excellent
first of all that was marvelous and I
want to congratulate the audience nobody
ever laughs at the plate oh [ __ ] so I
really I very much appreciate it's a it
seems to be a very smart crowd you don't
expect that in the library setting now
by the way this is where Dewey Decimal
is actually buried this is this is his
tomb the whole the whole decimal family
actually why do they name it for his
first name Dewey when his last name was
decimal these are the questions that I
cannot answer to you my son next we're
going to talk a little bit about
obviously the the presidential races are
on now our executive producer of the
program ben karlin who is sitting now to
the farthest right will be dealing with
i believe what are you gonna be reading
fun I have the honor of reading the
biography of George W Bush oh it's a
it's a marvelous piece of I believe this
is his official biography if I'm not
mistaken this is the one that is
actually delivered by the Republican
National Committee or this is on the
website this is dead this is taken
downloaded from their website yes if
they have the internet here but you can
download it your Internet's I don't know
which internet they have here they may
have
there are many Internet's we got this
from one of them George Walker Bush
hurtling the lowered bar
George Walker Bush our 43rd president
has overcome an incredible lack of
obstacles to attain his success born on
July 6 1946 in New Haven Connecticut the
young Bush had little time to enjoy his
tawny surroundings when Bush was but a
boy his father fed up with the lack of
oil in Connecticut moved the family to
Texas to fulfill his dream of being a
magnet the early years were rough as the
young Bush watched his father George
senior struggle just to find enough
decent servants to put food on the table
Bush was a realist he knew that to have
his way made for him in the world he
would need the appearance of an
excellent education but from where what
New England preparatory school worth its
salt would take a chance on a mediocre
student from a powerful family
luckily all of them George W Bush
attended Andover Academy where he fared
building on that momentum he put himself
through Yale though only after earning
the coveted Barbara Bush scholarship and
then war after graduating Yale summa [ __ ]
c-average George Bush suddenly found
himself eligible for the draft he was at
a crossroads should he enlists and fight
a war he supported or was there perhaps
a different less dangerous route there
was but it wouldn't be easy the Texas
Air National Guard selected only the
elitist
of the elite George Bush would need a
note as fate would have it his father
knew the people who could make things
like that happen five years later with
Vietnam winding down it was clear George
Bush had turned up for National Guard
service most of the weekends he was
required to still haunted by flashbacks
that it was the weekend he would have to
report to the base Bush tried to leave
Vietnam behind and somehow begin having
the pieces of his life put back together
for him armed only with a Harvard MBA a
Rolodex of powerful oil and business
connections and moxie George Bush struck
out he was eager to start writing the
story of his life chapter one chapter 11
Bush proved uniquely adept at driving
companies into the ground and was soon
bankrupting larger and larger entities
it was a lesson in failing he would not
soon forget and then a chance meeting
with the vice president of the United
States changed George Bush's life
the vice-president saw something in a
young man that's when George Bush Senior
offered George Bush jr. his support to
run for governor of Texas having never
held any elected office George Bush
found governing fulfilling while he
wasn't able to bankrupt Texas he did add
many new and interesting particles to it
ser always a friend to the energy
industry Bush tripled the amount of
electricity flowing through death row
even the [ __ ] took notice
Texas tamed Bush turned his eyes to the
Oval Office the 2000 election was
quintessential Bush he lost the popular
vote thus winning the presidency in just
four years President Bush has
streamlined our bloated job market
tossed over unnecessary ballast of
international allies and ensured that
our military does not become bored or
complacent he is widely expected to lose
the election serve a second term and
then be named Emperor in 2008 there goes
every Bush excellent work
nicely nicely read then I you know I am
NOT an expert obviously in the arts of
rhetoric or public speaking I detected a
hint of irony in your voice it was like
my steak that was my mistake because you
know it might also be because homage
that was puerile much thank you
that was terrifically done I noticed
that the audience booed at a certain
points typically regarding a body blow
if you will to the to the president I
think we might have crossed the line at
what point in that where is the line
it's dotted so sometimes it's hard to
see action I think it's an interesting
question for Center right now I'm going
to introduce his name is Robert Corey he
is one of our illustrious correspondence
he has stood in front of pictures in
Baghdad he has stood in front of
pictures from the Capitol he is I think
one of the top green screen
correspondents in the country the job is
always dangerous he is missing the
baseball game right now to be here and
that is a 28 to 13 wearing a fabulous
suit forget it this I only wear this
when I don't care how I look
well you look adorable and thank god
there's a podium in front of me that's
all I'm saying but the interesting I
just did a dick joke at the library
and it's the biggest applause all night
I think one of the Lions outside just
went to rob is going to read you know
very often in the political campaign
season people always say that the vote
comes down to who you would rather have
a beer with what we had done to put
together the election section of America
the book is sand Rob Corddry and Ed
Helms out to have a beer with each one
of these candidates
I believe Rob had a night out with John
Kerry and that is what you're going to
share with us right now if you would
thank you so much drunk or tree want to
see a picture of my hog before I can
answer the junior senator from
Massachusetts whipped out a small
wallet-sized photo of a harley-davidson
motorcycle in doing so he knocked over
his can of Iron City Beer into my lap
son of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
he spat out quickly wiping up the spill
with an oil stain bandana my bad man
the senator signaled our bartender for
another round I thanked him for the brew
don't thank me thank Saint Teresa that
was his nickname for mrs. Heinz carry a
nickname he tossed off with greater
frequency as cans of iron city gave way
to shots of Jack Kerry leaned into me
Terry's [ __ ] great he snarled before
mentioning the actress Morgan Fairchild
and that he had once - once tapped that
when it still meant something John Kerry
John Kerry is a regular guy real salt of
the earth in fact all regulars at Leon's
shamrock pub and Grill in Boston's North
End have been told precisely that each
and every time Kerry pops in usually
with a camera crew or an intrepid
reporter like myself they've gotten used
to his boozy ramblings and have learned
to recognize his warning signs my
heads-up came as a glancing blow to my
temple which knocked me off my barstool
and onto the floor as I came to I could
see interns restraining Kerry by the
fringes of his born to kill bikers vest
red-faced and spitting he yelled at me
police action the two pieces of shrapnel
still in my ass says it was a war truth
be told I hadn't actually called Vietnam
a police action but instead he said
instead I had said it's getting late
senator I should go Kerry's chief
campaign strategist helped me to my feet
don't take it personally he said the
Senators just so strong on defense his
warriors rage gets the best of him
sometimes another campaign aide clapped
his hands twice summoning two large
bearded veterans who went by the names
dusty and TJ they escorted me outside
and told me to stay there until the
senator cooled off as I hit the night
air I could taste blood in my mouth just
then the door of the pub swung open and
Kerry bounded out I braced myself for
another stinging punch but instead
he swung a sober arm around me pulled
his face in close and whispered don't
worry it's cool I'm not even drunk just
be sure to write about the part where I
hit you fascinating
a fascinating
really routes a fascinating first-person
account thank you with access that I
think is is unmatched yeah thank you
that if you're gonna read a first-person
account and I would say if there's if
someone claps do the clap yourself right
that engages the audience I thought that
the facial expressions you bought to it
along with some things that you've
obviously learned in your movement class
I'm reelin I'm classically trained thank
you
I'm classically trained really a
terrific work thank you
next one of the other things that we
wanted to do in America the book is give
our correspondents a chance to write a
more personal essay something about the
system of government that we live in
that would reflect more personally upon
them what I'd like to do is call mr.
Edie Helms to the tour ah to the podium
ed Helmes is our correspondent he's from
Atlanta actually where believe is the
headquarters of CNN I don't know if you
originally started with them
yeah I'm not allowed back no I didn't I
did not realize that what we did with Ed
is we wanted to give him some premise
oriented fanciful ed as as you know a
licensed Imagineer so we had did not
know that you are now a licensed
Imagineer library pattern he will be
reading an essay entitled if I were
president at homes thank you
if I were president by Ed Helms solid
start
my fellow Americans if I at Helm's were
president I would serve the country I
love by making things better not worse
for instance health insurance I believe
every American should have health
insurance so I would write a law giving
it to them and then I'd sign it right
away I also don't think people should
have to struggle to make ends meet so I
would fix the economy two no-brainer
people now it's no secret the
israeli-palestinian crisis has been
going on for months I'd get them
together let him talk
why hasn't anyone done that yet
sometimes the simplest solution is the
best one that was serious
the president is also the nation's moral
leader don't know how I'd play that one
if I were president I would end the
unfair taxation on tax the people
already pay it's called double taxation
and it's totally unfair right now Uncle
Sam collects 35 cents on every dollar I
make I changed the law so I could write
that off and only pay tax on the
remaining 65 cents at 35 percent rate
that would leave me with 42 cents which
which is it's actually less I totally
worked this out the other day like I'll
get back to you on the tax thing
what's the Department of Labor for
here's a shocking fact I once heard no
one knows if I were president it'd be
gone
unless there's something I'm not seeing
here also I would order the immediate
death of Roger Simpson the one who lives
at 1310 North 7th Avenue apartment 12a
Oroville California he knows why okay
that about does it one more thing in a
Helms administration Air Force one would
officially be renamed Air Force fund I
feel very strongly about this thank you
very much
marvelous marvelous thank you very much
thank you very much president Helms
because I really thought that you put
out a powerful case Thank You thanks
it's uh he has some interesting thoughts
about the Supreme Court also in the book
he doesn't have there's another essay in
the book where Ed Helms writes if I were
the Chief Justice which I think also
ends unfortunately with the death of
Roger Simpson the reason that we're not
sold at Walmart is apparently because of
one part of the book which is all nine
Supreme Court justices naked it's but we
also include their robes that you can
cut out and give them back their dignity
but we thought what better way to
demonstrate our First Amendment right
than humiliate the people who gave it to
us
finally I'm sorry Grover
it's that Court this is definitely a
place for for that debate by the way the
winner of Roe vs. Wade and this is also
in the book is going to square off
against the winner of Brown versus Board
of Education
it's gonna be roe versus brown and it is
gonna be a steel cage [ __ ] I'm
allowed to say that in a library right
now no you're not fair enough now to end
this and then we're gonna open up to
questions from the audience which I can
only imagine you're dying to ask us a
question I mean I can only imagine
you're sitting there going shut up I got
so many questions this is uh it's the
chapter number six called campaigns and
elections and it's the narrative thread
that takes us through Chapter six
campaigns and elections America changes
the sheets now that you have read the
first five chapters and assimilated
every word into the fiber of your being
or have randomly open to this page while
taking a dump you you are ready to learn
about campaigns and elections in brief
campaigns and elections are democracy's
vetting process democracy sounds good on
paper but how do we know it won't
explode when we started campaigns and
elections are where the idealism and
elegant design of the American
experiment are set free you see if they
can survive in the wild although the
skills needed to woo voters are at times
diametrically opposed to those necessary
to govern them the expensive and arduous
process exists for a reason to ensure
that those who wish to govern are if not
the most qualified our country has to
offer at least the ones who want it the
most the ones who want it so badly we
will endure any humiliation just to
catch but a whiff of the aphrodisiac
that is power power being defined as a
junior non voting appointment to a
congressional transportation
subcommittee
as Nixon famously said of Hubert
Humphrey his opponent in the 1968
presidential election yes my opponent is
wise yes he is honorable but is he
willing to kill anybody who stands in my
his way [ __ ] up that quote Nixon's
subsequent triumph was proof of the
system's central tenets campaigns and
elections of the process in which
democracy separates the willing from the
able and goes with the willing the most
significant change to campaigns over the
years has been cost and while if you are
considering a run for office you no
doubt have an impressive personal
fortune only the rarest breed of
politician can foot the bill on his own
such as billionaire Steve Forbes who
twice ran for president despite not
having a goddamn clue what he was doing
flat tax yeah keep saying that and see
if it sticks [ __ ] its it sounds
harsher when you say it really when when
it's a footnote it's really quite light
hearted
so that means fundraising and lots of it
savvy candidates know that without a
powerful fundraising organization they
will lose but I have a prescription for
what ails our country and can lead stop
you will lose and raising money takes
time so plan on at least a year of
non-stop solicitation to adequately
compete don't worry there'll be plenty
of time to come up with core beliefs and
policies after you've been elected still
doubt the importance of money in
political races billionaire Ross Perot
received 19 percent of the presidential
vote in 1992 despite being clinically
insane fortunately candidates don't go
it alone whether seeking a city state or
federal office they are undoubtedly
running under the auspices of one of
America's two political parties the
Republicans and the Democrats the
Republican Party is the party of
nostalgia it seeks to return America to
a simpler more innocent and moral past
that never actually existed
the Democrats are utopians they seek to
create an America so fair and
non-judgmental that life becomes an
unbearable series of apologies
together the two parties function like
giant down comforters allowing a
candidate to disappear into the
enveloping softness protecting them from
exposure to the harsh weather of
independent thought each party has a
platform or price fixed menu of beliefs
making up its worldview the candidate
can choose one of the two platforms but
remember no substitutions for example do
you support universal health care then
you must also want to ban on assault
weapons proliferation x' your
anti-abortion luckily all human opinion
Falls neatly into one of the two clearly
defined camps thus the two party system
reflects elegantly the by chromatic
rainbow that is American thought the
campaign trail learning to hate the land
you'll govern it is now time to develop
the strategy that will win you the power
you have craved since that beating in
eighth grade step one is to define
yourself distilling the ideas and
intangibles of your candidacy into an
easily digestible archetype can be
meticulous and frustrating work thank
God there are only two choices the
outsider outsider dome is the strategy
best suited to first-time candidates or
veteran candidates who always lose it
reflects the distaste the public has for
politics as usual and inside the beltway
experts agree the outsider persona is
the best choice for today's wannabe
insider you won't want to use the word
outsider too much in your campaign
however so feel free to have your team
of seasoned campaign managers political
operatives and speech writers use
synonyms like grassroots maverick and
populist just make sure no one looks at
your business card and decides to go
with billionaire financier the important
thing is you know nothing about
Washington and don't have a clue how the
system operates the insider in a very
likely event you are an incumbent the
whole outsider thing isn't gonna fly
time for Plan B running as the guy with
experience this means you are a seasoned
Washington veteran
who has gotten things done and risen
above politics to make the type of tough
unpopular decisions that have gotten you
re-elected to 19 consecutive terms in
the house you know everything about
Washington and know exactly how the
system operates that doesn't mean you're
out of touch after all
Hootie and the Blowfish did play at your
last rally and by all accounts rocked a
third option is running as your own man
good luck with that I'm cutting things
as we go because I'm boring you every
campaign features common elements all of
them are necessary one of them is
important meeting constituents this is
accomplished by interrupting potential
voters at a diner ask them questions
touch them
look at them not with disdain oftentimes
these appearances are accompanied by a
short distillation of exactly who the
candidate is written by someone else
these are called stump speeches because
they are to oratory what a stump is to a
tree endorsements if a fellow politician
celebrity or respected media publication
puts its support behind a candidate
voters will follow this is the theory
behind endorsements it has yet to work
in fact in some cases endorsements may
even hurt a candidacy for instance
Barbara Streisand
anything she touches turns to [ __ ]
advertising now we're talking hectic
campaign case got you down your opponent
seems to be right on too many issues by
advertising time it is the elixir to
cure any ailing campaign whether a
candidate is introducing himself
reintroducing himself explaining himself
defending himself reinventing himself or
simply destroying his opponent t v-- is
the medium of choice and here's the best
part there are no rules political
advertising cannot be held to the same
high truth standards of say beer try it
refer to your opponent as Hitler esque
you've got nothing to lose but any
chance of ever going to heaven elections
those were today it's finally Election
Day the day Americans celebrate their
democracy and while Election Day isn't a
federal holiday it is held on a Tuesday
for convenience on election day
Americans exercise their fundamental
right to vote or not 55 to 70 percent
vote for the latter it is perhaps a sign
of the strength of our republic that so
few people feel the need to participate
that must be the reason typically voting
is done in church basements or middle
school gymnasiums staffed by
well-intentioned volunteers whose naive
enthusiasm more than makes up for their
blind incompetence at their disposal
technology only fifty to seventy-five
years behind its time because if it was
good enough for McKinley it's good
enough for us with no national standard
for conducting elections ballots states
and municipalities are free to oversee
them as they see fit
ballots differ from state to state
though common elements generally include
a booth a curtain and a disproportionate
amount of old people
then just like that the results you
already knew from weeks of internal and
exit polling are in results usually go
one of two ways
you've lost thank your staffers they
could have worked harder but now it's
not the time to tell them that the next
step is making the difficult phone call
through gritted teeth and crushed ego to
your opponent though over the past few
days he has said things about you that
in certain middle-eastern countries
would get his tongue cut out you must
offer your congratulations and pledge
your support you will spend the better
part of the next three years working
tirelessly towards his destruction but
keep that to yourself
now go out there failure that you are
and deliver a concession speech allowing
you to exit the political arena with
whatever is left of your dignity the
cameras are on you are surrounded by
loved ones and supporters there is red
white and blue bunting that in your
current mood can't help but strike you
as temptingly flammable it's been a good
run good luck with your memoirs slash
consulting job slash extended ski
vacations slash slow depressing slide
into obscurity with any luck you'll at
least be a historical footnote or you've
won champagne you just got off the phone
with your douchebag opponent who's choke
back venom you couldn't help but chuckle
at [ __ ] him your junior communications
director is massaging your balls while
the deputy pollster works the shaft it's
good to be the king now go out there
before the cheering throngs and tell
them this is a time for unity and make
sure you throw in a couple of black
people and someone in a wheelchair
behind you to prove you meant all that
crap about inclusion enjoy the evening
cuz tomorrow you wake up an officeholder
elect and the real work begins running
for re-election
thank you very much now what I want to
do is first off I want to introduce Paul
this year and have her come up
she is the partner in pentagram which is
the design firm that created all the
design for the book and we couldn't have
been prouder to work with them and for
our discussion I have to tell you they
did the most incredible job everything
that we thought of in our twisted State
at whatever time of day through their
design and hard work they illuminated
and made much better than we ever
thought it would be so we owe them a
huge debt of gratitude and we wanted her
to be up here as well thank you very
much for listening to to our reading and
ask you if you have any questions and
then we'll open it up to that and then
and then we're all head over to pry
guess another library yes yes ma'am
well I sign your your books I'm
illiterate unfortunately I'd be happy to
I would be happy to sign your book
probably after the question and answer
yes ma'am
on the thing there yes ma'am yes I was
wondering with the motivation for
writing the book was if it was something
you guys had been planning for a long
time or if it was something you felt was
particularly appropriate during this
time period okay
we hate our families - talk about you
know then actually there is there is a
real what happened in terms of Ben was
first approached by this so talk a
little bit about what where that went
um well I was actually approached by a
friend of mine who's an editor at
another publisher believe it or not and
the kid press has anyone hated them
and he we were talking about doing a
book and I said yeah that's great we'll
just go with someone else he kind of
brought up the idea and we're like yeah
yeah yeah maybe we'll do that and then I
started talking with DJ a little bit and
David I'm sorry sometimes goes by DJ
that's his age so we we just basically
started talking about it and then we
said to John hey well maybe we could do
a book and then he said yeah that's a
good idea and then I said get Corddry in
here we need him Corddry we yes we
actually really did notice that all the
books that were coming out where we're
like these like we're right they're
wrong and liberals hate America and all
that and we just thought well why not
try to do a book that that just was was
funny but didn't really have a really
strong kind of partisan like make you
animals we're right you're wrong we want
to write a book that said we're wrong
which is a roundabout way of saying
ultimately I think it was a book about
how can we make the most money no in
many respects that is true it's a book a
book about hope I think hope I would say
so I think we all got together and
really thought about who's the future
and I think we came to the conclusion
the children you know in many respects
we were waiting for them to kind of call
to kind of call [ __ ] on us but
people are like putting it on
curriculums and syllabi now so right
which is I love that because if any
professor decides to put this book on
their syllabus you know they're making a
decision to put a book that was
explicitly designed not to be a textbook
on their syllabus oh it's quite an
ironing organic chemistry syllabi yes it
also you know on the show we use sort of
this false voice of authority that is
lent to buy you know in many respects
the structure of a parody newscast
you're able to sort of bring this false
gravitas to it and to translate that to
the page was not easy by doing sort of
an academic knockoff it allowed us to
sort of translate that that false
pomposity or as Jim Carville would say
actual pomposity
to the page and I thought that that
worked out for us
very well there is another question
there yes ma'am is this another roe v--
wade thing because I can't handle it all
right
I'm sorry tap into it
yeah I want to tap into your real
pomposity Ralph Nader yeah
what do you think of him and how much of
an impact is he gonna have on the
elections what what what do I think of
Ralph Nader yes you've been on your show
he has been on the show but I so rarely
listen to the guests
he seems sincere III don't know if he
honestly don't believe you know we were
talking about this recently that this is
a purely ego thing I truly believe that
he has his designs on a larger issue
which is that the political system
deserves a third party and so he's
looking at and clearly four people agree
with that position and so I think in
some respects were if you look at it
from the rational logic of you could
cost him mathematically the election
he's looking at as I'm not thinking
about this year I'm thinking about
twenty four so he's thinking about so
but but many people refer to him as the
air bag of our governmental system I
think to truly be president you need
more than one suit that's that's how I
feel about it yes yeah and I don't know
if you guys need the mic I think if you
just yell it and then I'll repeat it in
that way or use the mic because that's
better yes I might add is somewhat
critical of me because I get all are you
reading this well I wrote it down to
remember it awesome all right all right
so getting my thing back my dad is
somewhat critical of me because I get
that written down too
my dad actually is at the baseball game
tonight he gave me a spot to come to
this but um anyway uh my dad's critical
of me because I get all my political
information from SNL and this show is
that healthy the next question
does anyone want to handle this this
one's right up the alley
what what news you learning from manga
presidents miss faults and uh John Cara
salsa now how old are you I'm 15 so it
really doesn't matter I'd rather you
learned it from us than those thugs on
the street those back alley government
people you know people talk about this
quite feeling we get this a lot you know
how do you feel about 20% of Americans
getting their news from you I I would
think and maybe you can answer this I
would think that kids today are so
inundated by information that it's
almost brought to you automatically and
that to watch our show we assume so much
knowledge of the audience it's it's not
a very instructive show it's a very
reactive one so I imagine that it
wouldn't be very entertaining for you if
you didn't already know a lot I think
you probably know a lot more than you
realize
and are getting it from a lot of other
sources and are maybe watching our show
for what we call in the business shits
and giggles
that may be the case I learned about the
Afghan election results by watching a
cab go by and I read it on the top let
me tell you something I get 20% of my
news from that yeah too many kids today
in the 18 to 24 demographic are getting
their news from cab tickers and
especially sports scores I think it's a
dangerous precedent as long as you're
buying the products advertised on our
show that's all we care about I actually
get all my comedy from CNN by the way
who knew that the only people you
couldn't put in the crossfire are the
people who hosted crossfire yes sir
could you stand please and state your
favorite book yours of course on the
world stage who would you consider I'm
sorry sir whoa I'm sorry sir citizens
citizens only event I apologize
can we get security
no no go ahead who would you consider
more powerful the President of the
United States or Rupert Murdoch this is
it is this a trick question
now are you Lachlan I'm Frankie he says
who's more powerful the President of the
United States or Rupert Murdoch I'm
gonna go with and again we can discuss
this I'm gonna go with the guy with the
atomic weaponry the president anybody
else I mean the post has great reach but
I think honestly if if I were a guy and
I had let's say a tabloid and another
guy had uranium tipped bunker busters
I'd say the smart money's on that guy
but anybody who's running Bertelsmann
these days cuz that guy he's a comer
Bertelsmann I think what you're getting
at is is our Australians extremely
powerful and the answer is is
definitively no but was that assured you
think he was issuing us a challenge my
respects a duel another yes ma'am hello
my name is Lynn syrupy and the national
can be met manager for David Cobb at the
Green Party presidential candidate yeah
and I've been listening oh you know what
actually before we go any further why
doesn't everyone just introduce
themselves
son of a [ __ ] we
that's okay because you know I'm trying
to have a civil discourse that's exactly
right and you know there's nothing that
the Green Party is more known for than
sense of humor so proud no no it's a
great effort I was so proud so what is
your question
to listen to you on classify the other
day yes and so tonight as a member the
Young Lions I came here and I wanted to
say David Cobb is the Green Party
presidential candidate he's the Green
Party candidate the Green Party exists
okay you know what I'll do what you did
no no I hear you are you feeling like
the Green Party is not getting the press
this year that perhaps it deserves I'll
tell you what and I'm sorry I'm sorry
who's David Cobb and I am more than
happy to have this opportunity because
you know what the Green Party exists and
I'm 100 countries around the world
no one finish the Green Party's
imaginary everyone knows it exists you
can do more than just cook fun any jokes
right we do a hundred countries around
the world and you're going to countries
mr. Stewart yes I'm sorry I alright I'll
listen I'm listening I'm listening I'm
listening
please
help I'm listening I'm not saying I
busted so so right now we're going from
awkward and now we want to get
excruciating we feel incredibly
uncomfortable just like mr. Stewart
claimed to be after the crossfire show I
was very uncomfortable yes this is
honestly and I certainly appreciate your
sincerity and the question is is is that
we were sort of talking about the book
but that's okay and I appreciate your
obvious passion and I don't really know
what else to tell you because we
honestly can't really help I mean that's
I'm at I only say that to be honest with
you but I appreciate that I'm sorry I'm
sorry no I understand yes yeah I
probably respect you as well it wasn't
profound honestly it was I was just it
wasn't it was it just got out of hand
and I saw it in slow motion happening it
was one of those things are like your
little conscience guy was like shut but
there's nothing you can do at that point
so I appreciate it
you know I yeah
hmm okay all right okay thank you okay
no I got you I appreciate that thank you
but what's the dick joke angle I have a
really serious question which one of you
is single
that's at house my number is very nice
Edie do you want to get up and do a
little yes you know what I probably want
a one on one answer I can give a feeling
I could elucidate that point I'm sorry
that was seriously the Green Party is
the Green Party is adorable yes yes no
not again
I noticed that yes sir I noticed that
Condoleezza Rice recently busted out
under the campaign trail yes if the Bush
administration loses the White House yes
do you think there's room for
Condoleezza Rice in the Bride of Chucky
franchise with that poor head and he
didn't seem like much of a seem
relatively rhetorical that's because I'm
not sure what the question is I think
there's a whole lot we can do with them
you've come here tonight to make
statement one about their political
beliefs the other about the physical
attributes of these are actually could
you wait I just want to see the Mike
person run over here no I'm just kidding
Jesse huh I appreciate that
attempt he's joking making fun of my
father and Ed Helms is a black made no
actually it's funny that you asked that
because my dad is kind of a left wing
nut and he and what party is he a member
of Green and he we were actually in
North Carolina and and met someone who
was actually related to Jesse Helms and
we found out that Jesse was adopted into
the Helms family and I only say that
real last name
Goldberg so but I'm still single I don't
know maybe I'm the only person who's
noticed this um I am online a lot and
this isn't gonna get freaky
confessionalism
I have been noticing this chain of
events across fire appearance and the
book and and certain murmurings about
certain Daily Show people appearing on
in the democratic war room and my
question I guess there must be true
rumors in the media yeah to always be
true absolutely the obvious question to
me is are you or are you not going to be
running for governor of New Jersey
first of all to run for Sonia I'm not
gay enough to be the governor of New
Jersey you have to be a closeted
homosexual to be governor he's out this
is a library crazy do it yes ma'am yeah
that the president should serve for more
than four years the damage they do in
four is not enough for you they should
serve 10 right how long would you want
it to be yeah that's why they can they
can be president for eight years I don't
know if that's news I think she's saying
I think she's saying running into the
term so it's not so much about
reelection ya know it would be an
interesting system is to have let's say
the president just until he dies and
then maybe pass off to his son
yeah and then maybe you're onto
something is you would ensure a certain
lineage I don't know what if he doesn't
have a male heir well that's an
interesting question if he doesn't have
a mental a male heir then maybe that's
an interesting question maybe a male
cousin a brother could take over or
something along those lines maybe we
could create familial dynasties yeah
that's up I'm sorry Monica I don't
understand what you say you nailed I yes
sir
is that yours I want to use that I don't
think that's your quote sir
partisan puppetry yes sir
processor in the process well I you know
interestingly you know my comments were
very specifically directed towards a
certain animal within the media that is
and oddly enough not the place to have
the nuanced conversation I thought we'd
have but but I was not talking so much
about the political system as much as I
sort of look at and again I really you
know I've created a comic persona over
20 years for the very reason that
talking as myself is very uncomfortable
because I know me and it's not so hot
but on an honest like purely citizen
level it seems to me that the media has
two choices which is to bring clarity or
to bring static and my only suggestion
to them was they are sort of emblematic
of this idea of static not that they're
necessarily pure partisans because I
don't think it's necessarily
partisanship but it's this sort of odd
theater that unfortunately the secondary
you know effect of what they do is
politicians know that you're busy and
you don't have a whole lot of time to
pay attention to what they're up to
so it's in their interest if the static
is louder because like they've learned
that they have to speak in sound bites
with repetition to deliver their message
the news media I think has to then take
that to the next level I would I would
my first move would be to remove
advocates from the discussion and then
or let them come on but not as a host
let them come on and then let the host
be an expert and then they could do that
but again [ __ ] me what do I know you
know never like like that's the whole
thing is when I said that here's like
you're an ass
like boy yeah hey Don my name is Aaron
Brown and I'm probably part of the
minority you're Aaron Brown Aaron I'm
Aaron Brown yes I was like dude when you
have your maker on you look I mean I was
gonna say you should just go natural
because they [ __ ] you up so bad for air
it's horrible it's really ugly
um I am part of the minority I'm not in
the Green Party and I was just wondering
that I noticed you have one female
correspondent on your show currently and
do you have any female writers and
what's up with the big boys club just
wondering Oh question we we we don't
think women are funny
also we invited our women writers to
come here tonight but you know they got
lost you know they would drive in
also also Rob Rob as a woman I'm very
sensitive you want to add some of this
yeah I want to put your foot in this
wire we tried to hire Maya Angelou she
didn't want to do it all dick jokes with
her every punchline was like that the
answer is there isn't a satisfying
answer yeah is anyone does anyone have a
real barnburner of a question before we
go we'll take two more and then we'll
and then we'll go yes sir what foreign
policy now we're in the show rather
trilateral commission right here I'll
fill this one gun if Rambo would just go
back we could do this man
oh go ahead your accent makes you sound
so smart God do I think the
international community cares about
America the book they don't care about
America the country
why would they care about the book you
know it's it's it's interesting you know
we put a section in the book called
international house of horrors at the
end because as cynical as the book is I
think probably everybody up here if you
ever got us into a bar fight with other
people from other countries we would be
the staunchest defenders you know and
that's sort of how we feel about this
election whoever wins this system is so
much bigger than one man and you know
that's the beauty of four years is you
can only [ __ ] it up so much except the
Pitcairn Island Pitcairn Island I want
to go to and I'm gonna go with somebody
from way in the back there because
that's been an ignored so yeah way in
the back to Walmart I guess my message
to Walmart would be t-shirts for 99
cents how do you do it I know I you know
I I'm almost III didn't actually realize
that they had banned it I mean I I found
out I don't think it's banned in the
sense of you know I think they thought
like oh look Scalia's swinging pipe we
can't have that in the store so they
didn't do it but I don't it really it
really hurts them they're really not
doing very well their loss I would just
suggest that they just recently pulled
the protocols of elders design so
they're they're slowly fixed rate you're
not getting it this last question right
though sir
go Braves what's the score
six nothing is it six nothing I really
have to get the [ __ ] out of here tygo
we're gonna pull what are we doing that
is so great thank you all very much
we're gonna pull oh where do we gonna do
oh I'm gonna pull out a thing and then
one elegant is going to be killed and
eaten deborah birch gate is that' and
she's a guest of denver CO she is a new
young lion and thus must go through the
patty-whack machine i thank you all very
much for coming out it was awfully nice
that is awesome six ones